hi there steve goffin here today i'm
going to talk about active vocabulary as
opposed to passive vocabulary and active
vocabulary means output it means
speaking or writing in other words
the words become activated the words
that you accumulate i'm going to talk
about therefore active vocabulary i'm
also going to talk about
how you use tutors because that was a
question that came up
and
let me begin by saying first of all if
you like these videos please subscribe
give me a like if you want
but begin by saying that you know so
much of language learning is a matter of
attitude
getting the passive vocabulary activated
which means speaking or writing is a
matter of attitude
just like language learning if you are
interested in the language you're
confident that you can learn the
language you
you're confident that the system you're
using is going to help you
all of these
matters of attitude are more important
than which school you attend or
what book you use or anything else the
same with speaking
when i go to make these videos i don't
really plan ahead i am not afraid that
i'm going to run out of things to say
mind you i've been doing it for a while
now
i just go for it and i think when we
speak we have to have that attitude that
we're not afraid to make mistakes we're
not afraid to be criticized
we're just gonna go for it and whatever
comes out comes out
for example you will see
in a
couple of weeks a video that i did
with a person named mike who is a keen
learner of arabic and who lived in the
middle east and we spoke in arabic and i
hadn't spoken arabic for eight months i
had done a lot of input activity on link
saving words and phrases so i had no
idea how this would turn out but it
turned out
i miss some words i got some things
wrong but
it's amazing how
a significant investment in input
particularly where i save words and then
i save a phrase and i listen to the
phrase through the text to speech and
then i listen again to the same
content spoken in a natural voice it
just builds and builds and builds this
passive vocabulary this comprehension
which makes you comfortable and and
because then you you know you're going
to understand what's said and then
something comes out and you just have to
trust that something will come up and
there is no shortcut
you know it is only once you have a
significant opportunity or need to speak
and that you get to speak a lot that
your output
you know skills will significantly
improve if you are
living away from where the language is
spoken as is the case with my
arabic
i'm not going to get very good at
speaking arabic but i can build up my
potential through a lot of input
okay and as i've said before the passive
vocabulary is tremendously important
because comprehension is the core skill
if you understand
you will eventually be able to speak if
you don't understand you can't have much
of a conversation so now how do we
actually activate this passive
vocabulary first of all
you know let's start with the with
what is a word
because i've learned a number of
languages i'm comfortable with the fact
that we're just
basically dealing with terms here
in chinese most words consist of two
characters but you have to know both
characters in order to understand
the
you know the the compound
word the fujotsa which might even be
three characters so it doesn't matter to
me whether it's one two or three these
are vocabulary items that i have to
learn in persian
lots especially the verbs are compound
and so the individual components may not
have tremendous meaning but put together
as two or three
words in a way they become a word
you say equivalent to a word in english
and i just
learn them it doesn't matter to me
that's why i think for example this
discussion about whether you learn
words or collocations or phrasal verbs
it really doesn't matter you have to
learn these
call them lexical terms these
vocabulary terms you have to accumulate
them and so all of this stuff sucks into
your brain now how do you activate it
there are a number of strategies you can
write which i did for chinese because we
were asked to write if i'm not asked to
write i don't write so i just don't have
the discipline to start writing on my
own when i'm learning languages for fun
but when i was studying chinese at a
school i had to write and i think that
accelerated my
learning of chinese accelerated my
ability to speak the language so writing
is obviously a good thing to do because
you have time to think you can look
things up you can look up grammar rules
you can look up uh vocabulary and you
can you know structure something that's
a little more
you know dense and accurate and that's
training for
output you can look into if you want
your
saved vocabulary items and make sure you
use them so there's any number of things
that the reasons why writing is a good
place to start if you have the
discipline to do it which i don't then
the next thing is
if you are surrounded by native speakers
of course you can go talk to anyone and
that was my situation in japan at a very
early stage even though i didn't know
much japanese and i was continuing my
intensive input activities every
opportunity i had
whether it was uh you know in the
subway at the grocery store
even asking my colleagues at work to
speak to me in japanese i made every
effort to use the language because the
opportunity was there
but if i'm learning in vancouver or now
i'm down in palm springs i don't have
that opportunity so i continue with my
intensive input activities but at some
point i i start to use the services of
an online tutor
because
uh
okay
the disadvantage is that you can't do it
five hours a day but i might do it two
or three hours a week
and this person is obliged to listen to
you
and oblige to talk to you whereas you
know a random stranger may not have the
patience to talk to if you don't speak
the language very well
and so people sometimes say well how do
you prepare for a tutor
i don't do any preparing at a very early
stage in a language with a difficult
writing system like persian or arabic i
begin by
say taking our mini stories at link and
then reading them
with the tutor
during our our our lesson and then we
have a discussion about the mini story
so i have the vocabulary there from the
mini story i've listened to the mini
story ten times i've read it a couple of
times we read it again online and then
we talk about it so that's kind of a
lead into trying to say something in the
language but once i'm past that stage
basically we talk about anything and
everything and the good tutor is able to
ask you questions that get you to speak
ask you questions about things of
interest not just you know is it raining
in vancouver
and they keep you going so it's not my
i don't have to
you know i'm not stressed about
maintaining the conversation
the good tutor keeps the conversation
going and the lesson is strictly
conversation because
i can look up points of grammar
if i have a question of grammar
something that
despite having looked it up in google i
don't quite understand how the language
works i might ask the tutor in
the target language persian arabic and
the tutor will explain in my sessions
with a tutor we never ever speak english
we only speak the target language but
typically we just roam around different
subjects
the key thing is that i have built up a
level of comprehension that i can kind
of at least understand what the tutor is
saying
eventually
i struggled initially in korean but we
didn't have the many stories at that
time with the many stories it gets you
up to uh where you can basically
understand what they're saying even if
you're missing some words
and so then we have a conversation
and of course the the tutor has to be
encouraging you know i had a tutor i've
had tutors who give me a pained
expression when they don't understand
what i'm saying like huh
of course that's very very bad the tutor
has to be totally into encouraging you
so that you you you feel pumped up and
you want to go back to that tutor again
and then
if we speak for typically an hour the
tutor then while we're having our lesson
the tutor is maintaining a file in
google documents or something
of all the mistakes
that you make or all the words and
phrases that cost you difficulty and
then the tutor sends me typically either
it's if it's in if it's a link tutor i
get the report through link if it's not
if it's italki they send me a document
file of some kind and it has 10 or 15
phrases each phrase embodies
something that i had difficulty
expressing then the good tutors again
will record all of these phrases so then
i can go and prepare breakfast and i'm
listening to
these uh phrases
and it becomes and i've mentioned this
before it becomes a record because i
import all of these into link as lessons
so that i have a course at link which is
conversation reports so i have them say
in the case of arabic i can go back to
18 months ago and relive those
conversations that i had and it'll have
all the problem areas and it's kind of
fun to see that
some of the problems you had 18 months
ago you still have problems with and in
some cases these have become second
nature to you so
in these sessions with the tutor because
it's a protected area and i'm just
trying out whatever i can
use you know
i'm not deliberately reaching into my
passive vocabulary but as i speak i
surprise myself some stuff comes out and
uh and i don't worry about it much like
when i make this video here i haven't
planned it out ahead of time i have some
thoughts in my brain
similarly i go into these sessions with
my tutor with no real plan
except again as i say at the initial
stages when i'm so weak in the language
that i i can't really have a natural
fleet throwing
free-flowing conversation so we build it
around
you know content like the many stories
so i read and we discuss them but once
we're past that we're having an
unscripted natural conversation
it just comes out mistakes and all
and and you realize as you read these
conversation reports that you make the
same mistakes week after week after week
but gradually you improve
and similarly
it seems like you're searching for the
same words week after week after week as
i see that in my conversation reports
because our conversations tend to come
back to the same kinds of subjects and
it's the same words that i can't
remember but over time these words
gradually start to stick so i guess in
summary
i'll say that to activate you're not
going to activate all of your past
vocabulary because you need to have a
very large passive vocabulary in order
to understand what the other person is
saying but you will gradually activate
more of it more and more of it but it's
a slow process and ultimately to become
good at speaking in other words to have
a lot of active vocabulary you have to
speak a lot and if you're not in a
situation where you're surrounded by you
know native speakers where you engage
with them for hours at a time this is
very difficult to do if you're
you live in brazil or japan or germany
or somewhere and don't have an
opportunity to use the language a lot so
you have to be satisfied with continuing
your input activity
you know
engaging with tutors online and seeing
that very slow progression
and never ever worrying about it just
let it just let it come out
and you will see as i have seen that
that you gradually get better but the
progress is slow
but as long as the process is enjoyable
slow is okay
anyway i hope that's helpful
bye for now